everything i talk about i know is right
for me and i hope that pieces of it
might be right for others
period you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
so nervous hi michelle where are you
from
i'm from georgia amazing what's going on
so much for what you do
i watch you like every day you've really
changed my life
thank you how so oh my mindset
like i was basically before i was
following you
i was just trying to find out what would
make me the most money in life
and um i graduated with a marketing
degree went straight into sales for like
a year
and um i don't want to say i hated it
because my first job was pretty good
i'm so nervous i'm sorry don't worry
you're doing well my first job was
pretty good
but my second job i was so miserable
like
i i was just so depressed and then i
decided to move home
good and now i'm i'm living with my
parents and i'm
kind of trying out different things
because i've always wanted to be an
entrepreneur
and maybe not on like a huge scale but
just doing something little by myself
because i don't know it makes me excited
that's good how do your parents like
having you home they love it i'm really
close with them
so close to my parents too like i i
spent a lot of time with them during
this quarantine and like
it wasn't enough like it's so fun like i
i actually would live with my parents my
whole life
like super down for it i love it
i just um i'm gonna be getting married
in like a year so then i'll be moving
out but other than that i would live
here forever
i love that i love that i love that i
love that what can i answer for you
okay so um my dream since i was like 13
i'm 22 now has been to be a content
creator
and i'm still not sure what i want to do
um like
what topic but i've just been making
like tick tocks like
following trends or like random thoughts
throughout the day
um but i get really put down by
people's comments and i've been watching
what you say and like
how you say don't listen to them but i'm
just like a really soft person i'm
really sensitive so i have a really hard
time let me help you let me help you let
me try to help
yeah the biggest thing the biggest thing
that um
um that you need to realize is they
don't know you
and there's two things you have to you
have to be empathetic
and feel bad for them like do you want
michelle listen to me
do you know how sad of a place somebody
is in
that they have taken the time to watch
your video
and say something to make you feel bad
so that you can feel bad with them
do you understand how sad one feels
like i i'm not joking and i think people
think i'm just trying to cheer somebody
up
i'm not joking when people say [ __ ]
about you like you're ugly
that's stupid you're not funny you're
dumb that's wrong you don't
you you like i don't know how to do
anything other than feel really bad for
them
yeah it's what's really hard for me is
like i have a lot of confidence in like
my abilities and like i believe in
myself a lot but there was
a lot of people like commenting on my
appearance which is something that i
can't help
and i just think it's like a horrible
thing to do and
for some reason i believe it every time
like i believe that they say i'm ugly i
believe it and it makes me like not want
to post anymore
look i we all have confidence and we all
have
lack of self-esteem i in places for
example michelle
i can walk into an arena right now with
80 000 people right now
if somebody called and and said we need
you
it's the first public gathering in new
jersey you have to give a one hour
keynote
we're outside you have to go right now
we're going to the jet stadium that life
stadium you have to go right now
now i would be so pumped i'd be thrilled
i'd be like in the car thinking what the
[ __ ] am i going to say i'm going to be
like all right [ __ ] around
you know like um right i can do that if
somebody called me right now and said on
t with garyvee
you have to read right now here's a
piece of paper
you have to read this i would be
unbelievably
concerned i would be super like
self-conscious because
i am a very poor reader and like like
it just really really really is anxiety
for me like sitting around
like during like very like the high
holidays
like reading at passover like like like
i'm scared with my like my family
so so you have a lot of confidence in
some areas and in other areas
you don't just like every one of us the
reality is though
you have to recognize that first of all
looks
beauty is uncomfortably subjective
it's just subjective and you have to
really understand that the people that
are
saying that to you are in a really bad
place
you're gonna have to figure this out you
know that right
yeah in a good way like it's just
practice
it's like working out it's just practice
so what are like
practical things that i can do like
actions whenever i get a comment like
that
like is it like a thought that i have in
my head like
yeah what can i do to build that muscle
i
everyone's different let me tell you
what i do when you feel exactly like you
just talked about
i think you should make pretend that
your parents died in a car accident
i know that seems super weird what i do
is i go to a place if i'm struggling and
i
create a scenario in my head that
actually speaks about real life
and makes me realize that johnny 97
talk talk saying that i'm ugly really
doesn't mean a whole lot
in a world where i'm driving now to the
hospital and i've lost my two best
friends
30 to 50 years earlier than i should
have
that's one tactic i'm serious that's one
tactic
that may or may not work for you the
other thing that you need to do
is go to a place of confidence for
example
i remember in high school very recently
i remember this when i would do
really poor in school and have a real
tough day when teachers really [ __ ] on
me
right which was never fun even though i
was confident
i would double go home and like focus on
my sports cards
like i would go to a place of confidence
right but the number one thing you need
to realize
is that it's in your own [ __ ] head
i'm laughing because i'm watching the
comments
of like so many guys being like i don't
know who said that but like what's up
like i'm ready to slide into your dm
like you have to understand
like you're you're deciding you're
deciding that that person's right
versus the people that tell you you do
look like you're deciding you're
deciding
i know and i hate that we all have
things we hate
but you have to realize you can actually
change it but most of all
and i'm going to give you something
really important
i think the thing you need to realize is
that you can't take compliments
in when you get them in whatever you get
them in
it's it's it's why it's so it's actually
why
i find the most insecure people around
looks
are actually the ones that the world
collectively agrees are beautiful
really yeah because they get so much
positive affirmation
they become susceptible to the negative
so much more i've been shocked as i've
gotten older through the years
like boys and girls like that i i would
argue
that the attractive are even more
vulnerable to the negative comments
because they take so much pride in the
positive comments
i think i think the reason that i can
deal with my negative comments
is because when i get a goat emoji or
i'm the best
or i'm a hero or i'm a especially with
like now that sports cards are exploding
everyone's like you are nostradamus
[ __ ] you you you say you don't predict
you predicted this
i hear that and i'm like i don't know i
don't
i almost don't it almost doesn't come in
which also doesn't let you're full of
[ __ ] gary
you were handed out it doesn't you
understand
yeah i think couple things one is
perspective
you know ricky thompson saying you're
ugly versus
your best friend you know dying from
corona is a big difference
yeah and those things can happen in life
and all of a sudden when they do
people realize why the [ __ ] was i
worried about other [ __ ] right
number two trying to really really go to
a
place of positivity immediately as an
immediate medicine it's only a medicine
because you got to really work on the
macro but when you feel it immediately
forcing yourself into places that you
make you happy as a quick juxtaposition
which sometimes makes you not dwell on
the negative as long
number three and the most important one
don't let compliments land either
okay i really appreciate that before i
let you go because i'm not letting you
go that easy
one of those three resonate or don't
resonate like talk
um i think all of them i don't think i
take compliments
to like heavily i think what about in
other categories
what about in other categories good
grades
uh well um
like other parents liking like not maybe
you understand
not things where you're vulnerable in
the other places
yeah and the other places yes like i i
always
my ready let me let me show you
something all those years when my
friend's parents were like gary you're
so nice i'm like luck of the draw dna
oh wow yeah see
like got it yeah
yeah it makes sense because when i was a
teenager i basically
um i was always looking for like the
positive affirmation from people
and in school even up in college i was
always like
getting a's because i wanted my parents
to be proud of me i wanted to make other
people proud people be like oh she's so
smart
like so i guess yeah i don't really
take the compliments on tick-tock too
seriously but in real life i do
what else what about the perspective
what about
literally understanding that somebody on
tik-tok that's like why are you making
these videos you're so [ __ ]
ugly versus the people you love more
than life
literally being terminally ill talk to
me about
that have you ever tried you ever play
that game have you ever done that
i've experienced it not that someone's
died but like i've experienced being sad
about something that's kind of trivial
and then something
really bad happens and then i'm like oh
why was i sad about that now like
i mean can you give me that example i
can't remember exactly what happened but
i do remember being in that position
a few times good i'm trying to think of
it
let me help you even more if you can't
think of a specific time then the really
bad thing wasn't really bad
i'm talking real [ __ ] with you yeah
no really this really helps me and i
know this one's a little weird and
sometimes when i put this out people are
a little weird with me on it i'm like
look
nothing listen let this let the record
be stated forever
nothing i talk about do i think i'm
right everything i talk about i know is
right for me and i hope that pieces of
it might be right for others
period and the story signature done
so back to what works for me i'm talking
about real [ __ ]
i'm talking about really imagining
like the things that would make you cry
yeah
like who do you love the most give it to
me in the top five
my mom my dad my grandma my sister and
my fiance
great those five people dying
oh yeah like tell me like i always do
this like
on the day when you got your nastiest 50
comments
on tick tock you getting a phone call
from
your mom crying that your grandma died
how much
do you give a [ __ ] about tick-tock i
would
not care at all that
thank you so much you're welcome so much
please
practice that i will definitely
want to make pretend like i do multiple
times a week
like sit there and almost meditate like
oh my god
this person died i'll never see them
again
like let it set in because what happens
then is when you go on
your normal day that other [ __ ] is
[ __ ] trivial
so you think about it even when
something bad is not happening
like to just like throughout the day if
you're having a fine day you just think
about it
michelle i think about it every day
which is why every day is a good day
i like that it was so funny when you
just said when you're having a bad day
every day i have bad things happen
because i'm a very
involved in the world person people
try to drag me down business things go
bad
you know i have a thousand person
company companies getting sued
there's not a single day that i don't
have things
that would make other people because i'm
a real entrepreneur i'm full like that
like you know like every day i've got
[ __ ]
but because i do what i told you
it for me a massively
bad financial thing or or like really
like
nasty situation feels less
than one person on tick tock saying
you're ugly to you right now
and i want you to be where i'm at badly
so they don't [ __ ] matter 89 year old
michelle does not give a [ __ ]
about terrence 96's comment in 2020 on
tick tock
yeah the [ __ ] are you worried about
being ugly
or not being ugly anyway you got a
fiancee i know
i don't know why i'm here because i feel
like we talked about it
media have to be beautiful people won't
like them what's that
i mean you see like i think you said
something super ludicrous that i want to
talk about for a second what did you
just say
to all the girls on tik tok that have
like the following
or people on youtube they're all they
look like models i feel like that's the
only way
you know what a model looked like 20
years ago
no she was skinny as [ __ ] and her name
was kate moss do you know what a model
looks like now
she's curvy as [ __ ] looks like she's
from [ __ ] brazil
or to your point has the financial means
to have so much
plastic surgery that she can look like a
different version of herself or filters
or lighting or angles
what are we talking about here and
listen i i will never go into these
waters fully because first of all i'm
not a woman
second of all there's so many dynamics
in play here but let me promise you
waters that i'm very comfortable
swimming in
other people's opinions are the greatest
way to go to unhappiness
one opinion you of yourself
is the easiest way to get to happiness
you hold too much value
in the collective outside world's
opinion
and you need to systematically from this
day on chip away at that
and make them matter less okay because
what you're doing is you're playing one
big game of junior high in high school
yeah i hate it i really hate it let your
life
i watch 30 40 50 60 year olds every day
still live in high school i see 25 year
olds still living in high school
that what that's not fun
know there is embarrassed you're [ __ ]
helping so many people right now
you're a reverse of course really you
should see what's going on in the
comments
you're listen to me you're talking about
what is on the mind of 98
of young women in the world and i hate
that
like any different than anybody else on
this
every single woman and guy for that
matter under 25 is in this mindset
yeah people care too much now there's
and now there's numbers around
popularity yeah
i just wish people would like
collectively people would be valued for
like how kind they are
and how what you think we're trying to
do out here
huh that's what i'm that's what i'm
trying to do out here
yeah that's why you like my show that's
why you
that's why i've helped you we're not out
here talking about numbers
i'm out here yelling that facebook and
instagram and youtube should hide the
following count
when i'm one of the biggest
beneficiaries of it
i want it gone because i but by the way
this is not facebook and tick tock and
instagram's fault
this is human being's fault
[Music]
we can't have our value tied
up in other people's opinions ginger a
great community member said metric suck
they don't suck
our interpretation of them suck
the following count and likes don't suck
we suck at valuing
that over what we want to say and who we
want to be
in the world
you can easily win this game michelle
you really can
i'm gonna try it every day i'm telling
you it's about perspective getting into
simplicity
not valuing other people's opinions that
don't know you understanding that it's
judgment what do you think every guy's
the hottest in the world
no well guess what [ __ ] what's the
problem here like
like what yeah you know how
unhappy so many of those girls you
admire are
i have unlimited messages from them
about their unhappiness
you know how not fun it is when you're
26 and you're smart as [ __ ]
and you know a ton about health and
wellness or wine or sports cards
but because you're so attractive the
only affirmation you're getting is when
you show tna
you know how you know sad that is i can
imagine
it's real it's just like somebody who's
wealthy who was born into it who's sad
and everyone said well i'll take that
like
like you know everybody wants to live in
somebody else's shoes until they live in
somebody else's shoes
yeah there's unhappiness in every single
way
you can be lucky that you're the version
of what's beautiful at this moment let
me promise you this when i was in junior
high having a fat ass
was not hot
you may get lucky that your looks are
matching what the current world's
version of beauty is but that doesn't
have
anything to do with [ __ ] happiness
beauty is
so [ __ ] subjective yeah i really want
to get to a place where i don't care at
all
the way not to care at all
the way not to care at all is to value
kindness and empathy
it's to value who somebody is not what
they look like
you know you can do this but you need to
practice about perspective
like the hell and the health and
well-being of the people you love
is so so important listen the world is
the world's going through such a
transformation i really believe
that kindness and things of that nature
continue to grow in importance and will
and people will be valued on that
but you have to value yourself
on that yeah that's real
it's very real michelle like you like
you have to value yourself
on that
i never thought of it like that but yeah
if you value yourself on who you are as
a human
then the then the things about
looks don't carry weight right now you
value too much looks
yeah i do which is why those things
resonate with you
you're so smart um you know what
i'm just fortunate
it when it comes to a couple of very
narrow things and one of them is
just [ __ ] the simplicity of life
if you're willing to go there
do you feel like experience taught you
that or do you feel like you were just
born with
that mindset yep both most
both i got lucky with the dna
i got fortunate with my experience i got
unbelievably lucky with my parents i got
unbelievably lucky that i grew up
on my own two feet um
and i got unbelievably lucky that my
talent is observing people
and understanding truths that are
universal
and then keeping it simple and then i
also got lucky in that
my great happiness comes from providing
happiness
and a million other things you know and
that's and by the way
that's why i don't think i'm special
that's why i'm deflecting when you say
you're so smart that didn't feel good to
me
huh because it's back to like
how i've trained myself you know what i
mean like i don't want that
like as a matter of fact it's my biggest
gripe with my team i don't allow them to
we don't put out content being about
like i'm smart because i don't think
that brings any value to anybody
i'm smart what does that do to me it's
like i'm trying to bring value
please please please get your life into
perspective you'll be so happy you did
every day hold your grandma
my grandma's 85. you'll be lucky if you
have another
100 hours with your grandma
every 20 minutes you spend on crying
about rick thompson
saying you look shitty is 20 minutes you
could be facetiming your grandma
no i'm not gonna cry maybe i wanna cry
perspective really helps michelle you
know what i mean
yeah you know all of a sudden
you like it's just these kind of this is
practice this is you and i are doing
push-ups right now
you know that kind of like helping
people realize things they don't see
when you realize holy [ __ ]
he's right 100 hours maybe
the hell am i laying here for the last
40 minutes dwelling about
one comment on tick tock
yeah that really put things in
perspective and it's those kind of
things
over and over and not just the one time
you were randomly on with garyvee
no no next thursday in the shower you
know
two weeks from now randomly when it pops
back up in your head and then you
practice and you practice and you
practice and what ends up happening is
now you are facetiming your grandma now
instead of dwelling you are making your
own content so you're on offense instead
of defense
and it did it did it and all of a sudden
and all of a sudden next thing you know
next thing you know this is now your new
life this is how you see the [ __ ]
world
thank you you're welcome is there
anything that i can do
to help you when i tell you
that if you can one time
when paul shits on you
if you can just take that moment and put
it into
85 year old grandma time that's
a real win for me i can do that awesome
thanks for being on thank you hey
everybody on youtube first of all thank
you so much so humbled for your time
i don't want to watch but time is the
biggest asset so thank you for watching
that video
if uh if you got some value out of that
there's a plenty more where that came
from
feel free to check it out